dass wir eine spontan wenn ich du wäre
gerade 829 ich zu meinem auto in der
tiefgarage
ich werde jetzt hier 100 kilometern
wieder verflogen
freunde wir sind endlich in hamburg
angekommen
es war die schlimmste fahrt menz leben
also das jetzt nicht bezogen auf den
stau das ging eigentlich noch das jetzt
noch den ganzen tag schon schlimmeres
erlebt aber auf einmal mitten auf
erfahren wir sind nicht schnell gefahren
irgendwie ich weiß nicht 150 160 oder so
das ist ja relativ normal und dann auf
einmal sagt mit der reifen pannendienst
von meinem auto ja du verlierst ziemlich
viel druck aber dann natürlich erstmal
vorsichtsmaßnahme direkt aus meinem bmw
point aufgesucht haben wir dann alles
kontrolliert wir haben wirklich alle
reichen um auf luftdruck überprüft alles
gemacht eingerieben alles waren locker
drei stunden allein mit diesem reifen
befehl beschäftigt war einfach nichts
ging alles super weiter kontendaten aus
über weiter nach hamburg das ist
übrigens chris christie s zusammen mit
mir hier guten tag mit der linken hand
wie eventuell an der ausfahrt gesehen
habe war ich noch die letzte nachdem
köln nominiert zealand hamburg
angekommen haben ein hotelzimmer
bekommen im motel one und zwar erstmal
so warum was mache ich hier eigentlich
wo bin ich hier ich bin zusammen mit
chris beim virtuelle bundesliga bäume
wir sind jetzt hier gerade angekommen
emporio tower oder so
diesen mega spät ich habe das erste
spiel das beginnt in sechs minuten oder
so das ganze event läuft schon seit zwei
stunden hier so sieht das ganze haus
richtig krass einfach ich habe als
erstes spiel gegen den deutschen meister
gespielt und ich hab verloren
ich hatte sehr sehr nah ja ich meine
gegen den deutschen meister zwei zu
verlieren kann man mal machen erstmal
wie ihren süßen knuffigen jungen sondern
gehen wir hier lang
da gehts euch dass man das ist der 23
stock meinig
über hamburg das ist einfach so eine
wundervolle stadt mann dahinten ist
glaube ich die außenalster da wo diese
ganzen bildschirm drauf sind da kann man
ganz gut boot fahren wird bei sich
trampel boot oder wie das halt so und da
kann man halt ganz viel einkaufen gehen
so hier das weiß nicht europa passage
apple store und da hinten auch dass sie
so nice aus einfach ich weiß nicht ich
kann es nicht beschreiben also
jetzt habe ich das richtig gemacht was
ich mal weil jetzt hab ich die dinger
reingemacht ich hatte glaube ich 1 0
geführt das 2 0 gemacht und an das 2 1
doch einmal kommen jedoch ein bisschen
angst aber ich habe wirklich gemerkt
dass ich mich im ersten spiel wirklich
ich hätte früher kommen ist nämlich noch
einspielen müssen und dann kommt man zum
finale der virtuellen bundesliga weiter
viel erfolg und viel spaß beim nächsten
spiel dankeschön hoffe ich dass ich das
gewinnen
ich bin weiter wie willst du das in
einem wort beschreiben
ja ich würde sagen dass du eigentlich
unterlegen war aber in einem wort
beschreiben
da ist mal wieder machen also ich habe
gegen marvin verloren 0 4 und 0 führen
der ist jetzt im finale und das ist der
vizemeister vom letzten jahr in die
meister von benefiz meister verloren es
gibt schlimmeres sache dass ich ein
wildcard gewinner bin da ich
rausgeflogen binden haben chris und ich
uns gedacht dass hier eine spontan wenn
ich du wäre dann lassen das jedenfalls
sagt jetzt ist für mich wenn ich diese
aufgabe hast du schon dass ich glaube
geben jetzt ein bisschen herum
vielleicht finden wir schlecht waren
möglichen typen und der roten kappe
enthalten die augen zu geben
mit 119 minuten unterlag indy 56 hinten
und wenn ich du wäre würde ich dieses
schild was dort steht das zeigt was das
ganze ist dieses virtuelle bundesliga
event einfach mal nehmen und damit eine
schöne runde laufen was hältst du davon
sicher
kurz angemeckert ich habe jetzt eine
kleine aufgabe gegeben und zwar wird
jetzt einfach kurzen tag
diese dicken verdächtig lehrer und sich
einfach mal irgendwas nehmen
ein bisschen angst
lukas leider nicht geschafft
was war los wo ist mein getränk ich habe
die aufgabe gemacht allerdings herzlich
geklappt ich habe kein getränk kommende
vorangeprescht ist muss ich wieder
rausgehen
ich habe allerdings christ ich habe für
dich noch eine aufgabe jedoch mal
einfach der moderatoren ändern park nach
ihrer hin gemacht dass als die die
christlich 8
ich habe meine nummer von den laden hier
drin ist ja doch weg gegangen einfach
recht schnell noch mal einer hawker
pieper und zwar wird die hier vorne hier
wurden vorher die ganzen besonders
wichtigen spiele und die ersten spiele
und so was gespielt wird sagen
ich hab nämlich vorhin noch mit
viele meinten jahren
ich wiederhole
selbst
weiter müssen verzerrtes bild total
verzerrt alter falter sieht man dass
einer der bildschirm ist einfach mega
verzerrt sieht man das 1
wenn du die bahn ist es mit einer frau
zusammen sein
würdest du oben um fisch oder unserem
bevorzugen wenn du dich entscheiden
müsste also ich muss mich auf jeden fall
danke für die antwort was ihr daraus
macht dass möchte weil ich hier mein
akku ist
guten morgen
wie heißt hast du circa geduscht guten
morgen es ist gerade neu nur irgendwas
und wir müssen jetzt noch irgendwie das
frühstücken holen falls kanzler und auch
irgendwie 25 minuten gibt das heißt es
jetzt durch duschen blau und enkel starb
bei diesen jedoch gar nicht so viel
hallo freuen und herzlich willkommen
hier zum ende von dem blog ich weiß
nicht welche szene gesetztes gesehen hab
ich denke mal irgendwas vom strand und
wo fakt ist dass geraten krasser sturm
draußen und zwar dass ihr wirklich das
ende vom blog ich hab nichts mehr im
urlaub gefilmt die komplette reise
bestand aus in bielefeld losfahren nach
hamburg wieder fahren dort zum virtuelle
bundesliga event wo ich mit chris war
und von da noch weiter an die nordsee
allerdings habe ich an der nordsee nur
am strand zum paar sachen gefilmt und
sonst nichts
es tut mir sehr leid auf nächsten reisen
werde ich versuchen mehr zu filmen ich
werde es versuchen aber ich hoffe dass
ich der schnitt und alles wieder
trotzdem gefallen hat dann würde ich
mich über eine bewertung freuen und wir
sehen uns bestimmt irgendwann wieder
ciao